YouTube team assemble hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome to the
Blitz - Building Challenge we've got
[ __ ] hi guys welcome to another
challenge with Ethan and Tyler just wait
let me do my other bit didn't work
anyway we got ballistic it's here we've
never opened them before just for you is
ready so we've got many ballistic it
Ionia possesses one you too everyone's
okay
could it be okay you're doing great you
look great to me mama
you can you do it anyway so we got
ballistic kiss here who's never seen me
before but we saw him online we're like
hey we got to make those so what we're
going to do is we're going to without
looking at the instructions try to build
this in three minutes sound good sound
good wait and get to open the box
mark you want to play the bill back what
do you want to ballista package not this
kid is saying for the Roman design
hardest part only is a clock for simple
assembly zero control camp
[Music]
melissa in German is fun they stop
ballista in Italian is fun in stop
ballista in French is based on five stop
ballista in Bulgarian is by Donna
ballista in the country holy moly
ah anyway alright so everybody ready for
the challenge to start with on time
ready will it count our head oh wow
no we need a timer very fish don't what
you doing I did whoa disqualified and
now like in to participation no no no no
doing or you can't touch it for five
seconds okay yeah you get the
five-second penalty okay who's ready for
this you ready for this I'm ready you
five I'm tellin ya all right so ready 3
2 1 go
oh why are there bit dress oh no I got
it under oh no wait is a glue cute thing
oh no instructions okay yeah no
instructions if you do instructions you
get a penalty since the channel is the
bow is the string smells like burnt wood
yeah later cut 406 huh
there's so much rope oh my god
jump rope with this holy [ __ ] oh very
much I don't know how to make how close
are we all three minutes yeah one minute
one minute
oh god oh no
and wait okay the box oh I get it I get
it I get it I get it I guess again this
yogi alright so this is a hint part
there's a channel fat and this on the
top of it to make the bullet not like
there I'm assuming that igloo so we
don't have that sorry you've got to be
really gentle with this heart first look
that glue I think we split the bike will
be remember suppose have a lot of things
for you I can do Oh pens down I'm the
farthest along out of anyone sounds
about right
Wow okay alright Wow we all have the
same thing I'm still trying to figure
mine out I had a lot of good process for
what I was doing out Shattuck arising my
please before I was able to serve her
better
give you those navigation will probably
live it goes [ __ ] your pants you can't
do this young man did you just fit your
bandit
I hit my breaking news reason I will
alright fine bring your mind you yeah
bring no brings I can bring my kid
aqua alright forget the time or it's
gonna we're going to go for this one we
don't have blue so we got to make do
without food so look at the instructions
what are you doing you don't do the
instructions you cheater you get a
penalty you're gonna punish cheaters get
punished right anything right good
alright g2g punish you're going to get
punished I don't know what the
punishment is for you going to punish
these how I was gonna say which is all
of the interactions that maybe they do
it
no you cheery if you can't figure it out
then you're dumb he's below that but I
wanted to see where the good guys are
you pooping what do I do
wash your ass in the tub I want to hear
the water day has gone from bad to worse
how I always go in there
crisis averted not even choking I didn't
want to start the video when you had to
shed your pants
didn't hit me until dead I thought about
it before I was like do I need to go to
the bathroom before I start doing no I'm
fine
and then it hit me like a train and then
the pie to your lower loaded and we
figured out how to make these yet uh
yeah
oh we're now working against you we're
on a team and now you are not oh no it's
like opposite of gingerbread house and I
have glue you can buy backwards yeah you
can hide with it empty where's my glue
you don't have funny you don't get
people without food to make your post
just give self a good pop attack house
on them making the group but you make a
do I make dinner out without me with you
now no get a man glue you keep a bit
much
look like hey you at home there's no
glue yes our goods don't touch our glue
and I have my invited amount of solute
no you have no food you have to use
icing icing where is squeeze I think I
mean get squeezed in it man and yes
we grew again you can't just Park the
shitbox Queen oh please look it up
squeeze me
well it's getting me nowhere
okay ah squeeze it coming to a close
don't know it has do you hear yes
it has too much purple do it
it's all warming you [ __ ] idiot why
are you so sorry right oh wait I had to
come draw your bike
yeah yes I know I buy not advice oh my
god my brother why do I guess I can have
him business Oh Julian I wouldn't give
you squeeze lounges I always give Quinn
I plan I squeezed is amazing we commute
together
no no but I have a sweet hat lunacorn is
blue record you windy baby bike you plow
IQ that's right pretty hard to squeeze
right [ __ ] dumb thank you
okay time for a quick read you squeeze
out a spleen here I'm good [ __ ] latte
convincing is money I think you forget
that it not good looking from yes that
cranky to see you're wrapping a bullet
hit call I knew this upside down
Oh engineer Maya is a work in progress
Oh like it's wrong it'll be ill defining
time I got this
you don't think I got this raise your
hand you do it home did you take my
string - where did you [ __ ] this is
my string your string right there ho ho
you know unsafe work environment okay
I don't look [ __ ] to the seventy there's
like just like this doesn't make a lot
of sense so the only principle do you
have to understand about this is that at
some point you need to have tension in
these handles so that when they pull
back there's resistance on this band
even though this whole just don't let me
do my thang so that we pulled back this
ball so that it can project this bullet
as far as you possibly can oops idea
okay so I think one of these has to be
cut this is the part where the video
where we run out of jokes we're just
actually focused on trying to make it
work what is it can you read oh jeez why
did you think we could do this why did
we try I'll move this way yeah move this
way Jesus right when it is there careful
if you
after moving it has to be moved how is
that how is the icing actually holding
the hood
it's clue mark I need to cover again
that I'm not going to break me where's
that multi-tool we were on a same team
Tyler I actually don't know where I
don't know where you put it you know
where you put everything mr. well there
is another and we going somewhere
oh well I just caught it okay again you
owe me I was oh are you I am fine it's
fine it's fine
whatever buying time even the hahaha
three and what it is people try to give
the other kids burgers now so you need
any more glue marks thanks to you I got
a whole brand new crazy glue so are your
blisters coming
seems like you're pretty lost I know how
to kick improve it yeah I know
know how it works I know the main is
principle why are you gloating when you
have that no I know how it works I know
the principle Danny [ __ ] build it
no the prince will stop talking about it
and doing it this way wait for it
give me fire horn let me keep this
furnace looks like you've given up why
didn't we guys are now trying to cheat I
see oh good news I made it that's nice I
made it I was ok give your best estimate
if we were using the instructions how
long do you think it would have taken us
to boot definitely not pregnant yeah no
not three minutes probably like 20 20 20
we took an hour to do it
without now right um impartial judges
[Music]
whoa all right Tyler you start I've no
battles down no mine was up there I just
had wrested it because I was shooting
that you Hensel down we have to sit you
last time remember
yeah you kept working no no no no you're
done you're done Island you're done
you're done GI reason mine here it's
called the flicking ballista yeah yeah
look it and it must keep you and your
little part right if you add too little
pretty big yeah
are you done with your exporting anymore
yo alright well I've managed to create
the world's first wrist-mounted Bulova
watch be stealthy you wouldn't even know
that there was a ballista and by god I'm
looking right at him to kiss the eggs
again you will be able to skip into a
little bit so and then it's like you're
like lalalala going to the grocery store
enemies because another good two shot
look at the range of this bad boy not
ten feet away
no the test shot
anyway I share all this [ __ ] aside a
little white Avenger me to explain I
would like to yeah
innovation I want it I don't know I want
to I want to see what I don't work how
does it work yeah how's it work
come along right you see your enemy yeah
this is the King right here he's got a
cap your blow the bullet what what did
you use the hold it again movie you it
doesn't glue ah
sparkle gel glue
I've been writing a slide act this
decide what this is a little looks like
glue
what does it look like this yeah does it
look like to you
are you going to wear your Eamon ha
funny joke although is white and looks
kind of like semen what did you use the
whole jeers together glue that looks
kind of like semen yeah I'm on Ethan
side now yeah
when our powers combined you take my
wrist-mounted
technology on and you port with this can
also be angle Mountain please be hold up
there's a newcomer in on this one with
alright mind ready for battle
alright look hi it's war the wild right
we're gonna get engaged oh now it's war
oh no it's okay that's meant to do this
to enemies sorry
double action higher intimidating but I
think we'll see in the firing
well you can't assist it how how's it go
on its own yeah remember yeah exactly
seems like you're having some trouble
yeah that seemed to be working Tyler art
impartial judges who is the winner mine
or whether mine no what am i wrist
mounted under category such as in German
yes sir we will have artistic
interpretation deadly as utility and
deadliest mine hey all right
Quinn I can't climb in fastings would
look with yeah that seems right okay
steady we're here to learn from the last
time but we have not been good okay come
on all right Levi all right very clearly
what this says is I chose the right
profession and also we should not be in
around weapons or more specifically
Tyler should not be around weapons
goodbye okay so anyway that was the
ballistic challenge you can vote it home
for who is the real winner but it's kind
of obvious that none of us were know
yeah not a one of us did anything right
but maybe that's how it should be so so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always we'll see you in the next
video bye
[Music]